hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast high-throughput proteomic
applications using anti Dyk d4k magnetic
agarose presented by dr. betsy benson
R&D staff scientist and protein and cell
analyst i am exhibiting tears of lab
roots and i will be your moderator for
today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific for more information about
our sponsor visit WWF is calm now before
we begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during this poster
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen well answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
poster presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the poster
presentation please use the ask a
question box to let us know that you are
having a problem this poster
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the poster presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits now please join me in welcoming
dr. Benton I will turn the poster
presentation over to her
thank you and hello I will be sharing
with you several proteomic applications
that we have performed using our anti
Dyk d4k magnetic agarose and the
kingfishers flex magnetic particle
processor the Dyk d 4k tag is a common
epitope tag used for protein
purification the eight amino acid tag is
most often referred to as the flag tag a
name that was coined and trademarked by
Sigma in the interest of simplicity I
will refer to Dyk d4k as flag throughout
the remainder of the presentation
the flag tag is a highly versatile tag
in that it can be inserted onto the N or
the c-terminus of proteins that are
expressed in bacterial mammalian yeast
and insect cells as well as in vitro
expression systems the flag tag is
recognized by a high affinity rat
monoclonal antibody that is covalently
attached to our high capacity magnetic
agarose throughout the course of this
presentation I will demonstrate
effective automated purification of flag
tag proteins from multiple complex
biological systems focusing on three key
features that are most important to
researchers high yield high purity and
biological activity
you
table1 show
characteristics of the Pierce anti-flag
magnetic agarose the bees are composed
of magnetic highly cross-linked six
percent agarose they are ferromagnetic
with low remanence meaning that upon
release from a magnet the beads do not
maintain significant magnetism and can
be fully dispersed the bead diameter is
between 10 and 40 micron with an average
of about 25 micron
the bees are provided as a 25% slurry in
PBS containing point zero one percent
tween 20 along with sodium azide as a
preservative the binding capacity is
greater than or equal to 3 point 2
milligrams of flag tagged green
fluorescent protein or GFP per mil of
settled beads and lastly the flag tagged
proteins can be captured in as little as
20 minutes
one shows the purification of N and
c-terminal flag tagged sumo protein that
were overexpressed separately in e.coli
the proteins were captured with 12 and a
half microliters of settled anti-flag
magnetic agarose washed and then eluded
with 0.1 molar glycine with a pH of 2.8
sustained gel shows each lysate and the
purified proteins in duplicates
negligible nonspecific binding to the
bees is resulted in high purity protein
recoveries as shown
you
figure 2 shows the purification of 1x
and 3x flag tag tnf-alpha from XP Cho of
media each protein was expressed
separately in the xB Cho expression
system where they were secreted into the
media purification of the proteins was
performed in replicates of six on the
kingfisher flex instrument point four
mils of clarified media was incubated
with 50 microliters of settled beads for
one hour
the bees were washed and then eluded
with 0.1 molar glycine at pH 2.8 belowed
flow through zan delusions were
evaluated by stained sds-page in panel a
the left side of the gel shows minimal
to no protein remaining in the
flow-through
indicating efficient capture the right
side of the gel shows single equivalent
bands of eluded protein with no
background
you
protein yield was measured in each elias
by protein assays shown in panel B the
average amount of protein purified was
about a hundred and ten micrograms of
the One X flag tag tnf-alpha and 162
micrograms of three X flag teched-out
tnf-alpha the standard deviations were
less than three and corresponding CDs
were less than three percent it's
important to note that the difference in
protein yield is not reflective of the
difference in tag length but rather in
the difference in expression efficiency
each protein each purified protein was
further evaluated using a be a core
instrument and their binding kinetics
are shown in panel C flag antibody was
captured on a chip using a goat anti rat
AGG and then the purified proteins were
passed over the chip the data shows a
four-fold faster on rate or ka for the
3x tag but the off rate is similar for
both tags allowing for a 20 to 60 minute
bind or capture step there is
essentially no difference between the
one X and 3x flag tags at equilibrium
figure 3 shows the activity of the
purified 1x + 3 X flag tag tnf-alpha
HeLa cells were treated with and without
tag TNF alpha as well as TNF alpha
without a flag tag following 20 minutes
of treatment the cells were lysed and
partitioned into cytosol ik and nuclear
fractions the fractions were analyzed by
Western blot for the nuclear
transcription factor NF kappa-b P 65
which is known to translocate from the
cytosol into the nucleus upon cell
treatment with TNF alpha the treatments
are shown across the top of the block
and cytosol and nuclear fractions are
designated as C and n respectively in
the absence of TNF alpha nearly all of
the NF kappa-b is found in the cytosol
in contrast TNF alpha both with and
without a flag tag is shown to promote
transport of NF kappa-b into the nucleus
the data demonstrates that purification
with anti flag magnetic agarose
maintains the biological activity of
purified flag tag protein
figure 4 shows the purification of
c-terminal flag tagged green Rinella
luciferase expressed with a high yield
in vitro translation kit the protein was
immunoprecipitated with Pierce anti-flag
magnetic agarose and sigmaz anti-flag m2
magnetic beads on the Kingfisher flex
the bees were washed and then
competitively alluded with tree X flag
peptides panel a shows a Western blot of
the starting lysate
flow through L youit's and post Aleutian
B boils results for duplicate samples
are shown and all fractions were
normalized by volume significantly
higher yield was seen with a thermal
scientific anti-flag magnetic agarose to
evaluate nonspecific binding to the
beads the elements were resolved on a
gel and silver stained the only band
visible is the flag tagged green Rinella
luciferase indicating very low
background with both thermal and
competitor anti-flag magnetic beads
panel see shows the relative
fluorescence units of the eluded flag
tagged green rinoa luciferase
the amount of active protein seen with
the anti flag magnetic agarose is about
five times higher than competitor beads
corresponding to the Western blot
showing significantly more eluded
protein with a thermo scientific beads
overall the data shows that eluded
proteins maintains biological activity
throughout purification mass
spectrometry is a key proteomic
application that can be used to identify
multiple protein protein interactions in
a code immuno precipitation in Figure
five the terminal flag tagged bad
protein was transfected into HEC two
nine three cells and then that protein
was immunoprecipitated
from satellites aid with anti flag
magnetic agarose on a kingfish reflects
non transfected cells were used as a
control
annaleigh shows a Western blot of both
lysate and eluded protein that were
probed with anti bad antibody on the top
panel and anti-flag antibody on the
bottom bad is clearly seen in both life
state and LU 'it of transfected cells
but not in the control the le woods were
next analyzed by mass spectrometry to do
this the le wits were processed in
solution digested with trypsin and
analyzed by nano LC ms/ms using a thermo
scientific dye onyx nano LC system and a
qs active HS mass spectrometer the top
three peptides identified for the Lu it
from the lysate with expressed flag tag
bad correspondent to the bad protein the
non transfected control did not contain
any bad peptides
next protein-protein interactions were
identified using thermal scientific
proteome discover to point to software
and string database the bad protein as
well as multiple known interactors
including several isoforms of the
protein 14 3 3 and mitogen-activated
protein kinase 9 were identified panel D
shows the interactions of all of these
proteins with bad in a string diagram
you
figure six shows the immuno
precipitation of nanogram quantities of
flag tag protein that was spiked into a
mammalian cell lysate here twenty five
nanograms of n-terminal flag tagged
green fluorescent protein or GFP was
spiked
into a five four nine cell lysate and
captured using anti flag magnetic a
gross or Sigma's anti-flag m2 magnetic
beads using the Kingfisher flex tag
protein was alluded with point one molar
glycine at pH two point eight and
analyzed by Western blots going from
left to right the starting life state is
shown followed by duplicate Aleutians
and duplicate post dilution bead boils
yield of tagged GSP is seen to be higher
with thermal magnetic agarose verses
competitor beads indicating that the
higher capacity thermal beads are more
effective at capturing low abundant
targets
the Elliots were also run on a silver
stain gel to evaluate nonspecific
binding the only band visible is that of
the tag GFP with the thermo scientific
beads background for both thermal and
competitor beads is seen to be
negligible
you
in conclusion the Pierce anti-flag
magnetic aggros purifies biologically
active flag tag proteins with negligible
nonspecific background both the 1 X and
3x flag tag proteins are purified with
similar efficiency mass spectrometry can
be used to identify protein protein
interactions from immuno precipitations
and co-immunoprecipitation x' with
anti-flag magnetic agarose and lastly
both abundant and low abundance flag
tagged proteins ranging from nanogram up
to milligram quantities can be
efficiently purified from complex
biological systems with Pierce anti-flag
magnetic agarose
this concludes our presentation thank
you for your attention I'm happy to
answer your questions
Thank You dr. Benton's for that
informative poster presentation we'll
now start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your poster
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for now let's begin
first question is what are
benefits of using high-capacity magnetic
beads with Co IP
high-capacity beads work very well for
capturing low abundant targets you saw
that in the the last figure of the
presentation figure six
the reason for this is that do the
higher capacity you can capture more of
the available target in the lysate we've
seen higher yield in both Western blots
as well as in mass spectrometry of IP
life sites
you can also use in the case of magnetic
beads where say you have a higher
capacity than you might need you can use
less beads which will lower your cost
per sample and in addition if you can
use less beads potentially you can
reduce your background if you're working
with a particularly sticky sample
all right and can the flag tag be
removed yes the flag tag can most
definitely be removed and Terrell kinase
is the enzyme that can be used to remove
the flag tag on the n-terminus of a flag
tag protein the enzyme recognizes the
full flag tag the Dyk d4k sequence
cleaving after that last lysine residue
completely removing the tag from the
protein
again looks like we have one more
question where can I find Kingfisher
protocols for the anti flag magnetic
agarose our Kingfisher protocols are
these for the bees can be found on the
product page online at thermal Fisher
comm specifically if you're looking at
the product page for the anti flag
magnetic agarose you would go to the
bottom of that page under product
literature where that the links are
listed
you
well I would like to once again thank
dr. Benton for her poster presentation I
would also like to thank Thermo Fisher
Scientific for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for an
on-demand viewing through September of
2019 we share with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye